hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from one of my newsletter readers Emily
wrote in asking thank you for the
articles are so encouraging please keep
it up I would like to ask this question
since i work with managers who are still
in the stone age and would not like to
embrace technology what is your personal
experience with 21st century managers or
managers who are stuck in the past and
what would the impact be on the
employees in the organization so that
can be really frustrating situation to
wanna push initiative through and you're
stuck with somebody a hug ahead of you
who is blocking your ideas and it's a
lot of reason why people go and start
their own business because they have
losses and managers who they don't like
and the fuel are stuck in the stone ages
and aren't listening to their their
ideas in position so maybe between an
entrepreneur is your path but if it's
not how to change the structure and
organization it can be really tough for
someone who's used to doing things a
certain way to change the way they do it
so especially not older company more
established business and managers who
may have been in the role for a long
time they have certain patterns we're
doing things and that can be really hard
to change the best way I've found to do
it is to not propose huge big sweeping
changes which would scare people off but
really really small steps so think about
whatever you're trying to change
hopefully you're on the same page in
terms of the the end goal as your mana
fix we both are trying to accomplish the
same thing you just have you have a
better faster cheaper more awesome way
of going about doing it so if you're on
that same page and try to find that the
smallest step to get the fastest win so
you're not going to go and accomplish
your whole goal overnight but what's the
smallest step that you can immediately
get some results from now very quickly
get some results fuel to show them say
hey this is working I try to do it so
that you're not investing any of the
firm's money try to make it more of your
we try to get a free trial if you're
trying to use some software try to
really bootstrap it up right the more
time it takes and the more money that a
cost especially on the money side then
the more your manager is going to say no
right there knowing about the budget but
if you can show that it's having an
impact and they're able to accomplish
their goals much more quickly more cost
effectively than otherwise then you have
a greater transferable to sell it up and
be able to get budget for it so start on
a small scale don't be a huge program
that might scare them off it's a really
small try to get a quick win without
having to spend any money and then build
a case to say but we were able to get
this far without any money now if we
invest just a little bit we'll be able
to accomplish a lot more and achieve
results much it was much greater success
than what they're currently doing as you
see they're stuck in the Stone Age so
again you know make that in small chunks
as you go forward even your next pitch
after you have your first small success
still make it a small trial so I can
only ask for a little bit of money a
little bit of time and continue to show
the what you're doing is having a lot of
success and then it's easier for them to
say okay keep going here's more money
here's more time you just try to reduce
the risk as much as possible and show
them that you have great ideas that can
move the company forward if that doesn't
work out you can always go cert your
business as well and hopefully have some
luck as an entrepreneur I hope you guys
liked the video if you did please give
it a thumbs up seeing those thumbs ups
come in making one of the more these
videos to you guys and we have a
question about this video or another
question about your business feel free
to leave in the comments below I always
check those out and we'll see you on the
next episode
you